c'est la fin d'une procédure judiciaire
de plus de 20 ans la condamnation de
maurice papon à 10 ans de réclusion pour
complicité de crimes contre l'humanité
est définitivement et définitive la cour
de cassation en effet rejeté le pourvoi
formé par l'ancien fonctionnaire de
vichy
mais maurice papon remise en liberté il
y a deux ans pour raisons de santé veut
désormais obtenir une révision de son
procès pascal justice la cadette la
condamnation de maurice papon à dix ans
de prison et bien désormais définitive
hier soir la cour de cassation a rejeté
le pourvoi formé par l'ancien secrétaire
général de la préfecture de gironde
condamné en 98 pour complicité de crime
contre l'humanité
cette décision met fin à une procédure
judiciaire longue de 23 ans
mais maurice papon persiste il va
bientôt demander la révision de son
procès c'est à dire un second procès
pour cela ses avocats s'appuient sur un
arrêt du conseil d'état rendu en 2002
qui rend l'état français responsable de
l'exécution des ordres n'agit pas a
reconnu la participation historique et
juridique de la france aux déportations
par l'intermédiaire de son
administration et dans le cadre des lois
de vichy
voilà ce qu'a dit le conseil d'état en
2002 ce qui est totalement
contradictoire avec la condamnation par
la cour d'assises de bordeaux confirmé
par la cour de cassation condamnation
par la cour d'assises de bordeaux qui l
a jugé un homme seul en estimant qu'ils
avaient agi en dehors des autorités
publiques et en dehors des cas prévus
par la loi cette procédure inhabituelle
aurait peu de chances d'aboutir
ses côtés des victimes l'arrêt de la
cour de cassation est un soulagement
même si nous connaissons un relâchement
est un soulagement
c'est bien que les choses se passent
correctement
il ya un point noir cependant c'est que
papon vit toujours en liberté
alors qu'il devrait être dans un
établissement hospitalier 40 définitive
quand on est responsable condamné à dix
ans de réclusion
on n'a pas droit à beaucoup de
complaisance incarcéré en octobre 99
maurice papon a été remis en liberté en
2002 en raison de son état de santé
il est à ce jour le seul ancien
fonctionnaire de vichy condamnée au
titre des persécutions contre les juifs
pendant l'occupation